on essaie de s'occuper comme on peut
c'est sûr qu'il ya un peu d'abattement
leur moral ressemble au printemps
maussade le fait que tout les jours se
ressemblent plus à un moment donné psy
s'est dit qu'est ce que je faisais il ya
une semaine qu'est ce que je fais il ya
trois jours je m'en rappelle même pu
croquer on est beaucoup plus à fleur de
peau c'est juste beaucoup plus
d'irritabilité sais que mes bateaux spm
maîtrise jours et il y à des deuils à
faire c'était supposé être mais demi
finales de basket puis souhaité annuler
complètement
on s'était quand même rendu là on aurait
pu se rendre - donc moins honnêtement ça
me fait de la peine parce que c'était ma
dernière saison au secondaire on n'a
aucun contrôle sur ce qui se passe on
sait pas quand est-ce que ça va finir
ils peuvent se sentir seuls ils sentent
isolés il ya beaucoup de conflits aussi
qu'ils peuvent éclater à la maison en
étant confiné 24 heures sur 24
tel jeunes a augmenté le nombre
d'intervenants pour répondre aux
demandes en hausse de 30% depuis la mi
mars
la détresse l'anxiété la déprime domine
on dit que les jeunes sont très
connectés sur les réseaux sociaux
chi chi texte beaucoup mais ce qu'on se
rend compte en ce moment c'est que ce
qui leur manque c'est le contact humain
c'est plus facile de se parler aux
personnes je pense je pense surtout à ma
meilleure amie puis aussi un chez moi on
est cinq fait quand on parle par
facetime est toujours des gens qui cote
ils cohabitent avec les soucis de leurs
parents m'ont mes parents travaillent à
l'extérieur
nous avons près moi et mon frère on
prépare les reports auront fait le
ménage de la maison la mère de béatrice
et médecins j'ai vu ma mère revenir dans
l'abattement dans l'impression d'être au
front un peu de la guerre de cette
guerre invisible up mais gégé les vu
capoter une île qui s'entraînent tous
les jours
s'inquiète pour sa grand mère elle est
testée positive pour le cours d'un virus
puis en ce moment sa situation est très
instable je dirais la rétine man juge
que c'est si affreuse peu pour l'avoir
alors leur moral sur une échelle de 10
j'arrêterai c'est sauvé sur dix sont
censés comme un set on dresser sais pas
je vais pas hyper mal mais je vais pas
super biais non plus 7 7 points 5 sur 10
considérant que d'habitude juin 9.5
dit-elle jeunes a constaté une deuxième
vague de déprime la semaine dernière
quand les élèves du secondaire ont
appris qu'il ne retournerait plus en
classe mais en tant que seront leurs 5
le fait de savoir que notre dernière
journée à l'école on savait pas que
c'était notre dernière journée à l'école
puis je pense que tout le monde aurait
voulu profiter d'une ère fois pour dire
au revoir aux amis qu'on sait qu'on va
pas nécessairement revoir à remercier ou
juste à les voires des preuves qu'on
apprécie ou non un parcours juste le
fait d'entendre la dernière cloche pour
savoir que c'est la dernière cloche que
tu entends sur les sur les deux milieux
qui est en transit dans ta vie ici à
nourrice despatie radio canada montréal